dan bajeena was a former Secret Service
agent and the author of the new book spy
gate the attempted sabotage of Donald J
Trump dan thanks all for coming on
tonight it seems to me if the press has
any role at all it's to make certain
that people who've amassed an enormous
amount of power power to affect your
life ought to be under lent with
scrutiny and yet what they're telling us
on the other channels all day long is
that it's somehow immoral for us to ask
obvious questions like why would John
Brennan have a security clearance as an
NBC employee why are they you tamping
down any effort to ask obvious questions
about what our government is doing well
you would think so Tucker but we're
dealing with a modern-day Pravda you
understand that John Brennan was the
puppet master of the entire scheme to
violate the civil liberties of Donald
Trump and his team John Brennan was that
guy John Brennan Tucker tweeting today
about his principles I thought it was a
joke I had a check for the blue
checkmark John Brennan has no principles
this is a disgraceful human being who
nearly destroyed the reputation of the
intelligence community Tucker on August
25th of 2016
John Brennan himself this is a fact it's
public record one briefed Harry Reid up
on the hill about elements in the
dossier that then made it into a letter
from Harry Reid to the FBI that was used
as a a predicate to spy on the Trump
team and we're supposed to trust this
guy this guy should get off Twitter and
hire a lawyer well but I also thought we
were supposed to be impressed by him I
mean I don't call me naive but I grew up
imagining the heads of our Intel
agencies were sophisticated and
intelligent everything I have ever read
by John Brennan is banal it's a cliche
it's pompous it's stupid he doesn't seem
like an impressive person how did he
wind up running the most powerful Intel
agency in the world do you know yeah
yeah I'm not quite sure because when I
worked in the White House I remember
crossing paths with Brennan and found
him to be a narcissistic fool I'm just
like he is now this man is really a
disgrace and a stain in the United
States whose legacy will only be as a
cautionary tale told to future CIA
leaders about how not to act
Tucker keep in mind too back as far back
as 20
fifteen left-wing reporters because they
thought they had a trump collusion
conspiracy which never existed were
reporting on Brennan's contacts with
foreign Intel about Trump and his
relationship with the Russians that
never came to fruition suspiciously some
of those foreign intelligence heads
resigned right after the Donald Trump
election rather abruptly they were
communicating with John Brennan who by
the way also is on the record saying on
TV with Chuck Todd and others and in
media appearances that he still has no
hard evidence of collusion yet he
weaponized the government in order to
attack Donald Trump he needs to slither
away quickly
what's that how's the next president
gonna deal with this I mean now that you
know the veil has been removed and we
have some sense of what's going on
beneath well any president ever trust
any Intel agency ever again not to
undermine him you know Tucker I'm not
I'm not sure about that and that's
really what upsets me having served
under two Democratic presidents as a
Secret Service agent and and listen I'm
not I'm a sinner like everyone else I'm
not looking for your pat on the back or
anyone in your audience I the taxpayers
paid me well to do it I never once
thought even in my own books about
taking a personal shot at Barack Obama
using my experiences never you just
don't do that when you sign up for
public service no less run the CIA and
then you turn around and turn to Twitter
to attack the sitting president now now
he's a stain on the country we deserve
better than this
I think that's right dan thank you very
much for that